foreign
[Music]
and one plus zero I'm fine with that all
right sounds good to me
all right let's go guys I'm going to uh
do us proud here right okay oh God
everything right okay great
well if you had bought the corsaman you
know is this in the quarters are you
scared of this line
it is
forgot a lot of lines but not this one
governor yeah this is where my knowledge
ends
so surely we have to be equalizing trade
and trade man surely
you think I'm gonna miss that murder
girl you're wrong
oh [__]
you know could have
could have played the difference I'm
gonna turn this into a nice
I believe I have two minor pieces and
you have one
uh it's by the number
yeah what's one what's two
okay
we're doing the stuff
never hurts to threaten to threaten
you think I'm gonna I think that's
that's gonna make me scared girl
you know I was hoping you could blunder
at least one thing today
single blunder six blunder averages I
think what I'm aiming for
I forgot what my ultimate strategy is
which is flag flying flag
how many times have I been faced with
that we have Queen yeah we've had Queen
G3 Queen D4 so many times
tragic
after 94 it became tough yeah I'd like
to say that I tracked that one up to the
peace blunder at the time yeah
[Music]
laughs
again insane
see London expert playing the one
every minlay s
he always has these positions I tell you
always except with the better slightly
better fine structure on the king side
yeah
no I can't give you the pleasure of
winning that position
yeah you like it actually actually goes
through my brain sometimes when I'm
playing like a someone who's streaming
I'm like no no I can't go down like that
you can't let them yeah have their
moment in the Sun
there's no way
[Music]
very nice
maybe something I know what you're
thinking
I'm not thinking it
too much time
that's actually what's gonna happen
oh whoa what was that
I thought he would play
surely he's going for a draw guys yeah
of course
early he was playing for draw
oh it's objectively the best result was
to take abroad so obviously I'm dealing
with just a dirty Flagger here
I have this down too oh this line again
great memories from this one I think I
think there's a Blitz game I had read
about recently
in Charlotte
a city in North Carolina
but this [__]
oh it's the best of the best it's right
here exactly
dang
dang question mark I'll take that
governor
I'm gonna have to go that way yes you
are a girl and you're gonna run very far
as fast as your legs will carry it
okay position has never looked worse
it's uh also never getting better
also never looks playable which is
what I need a playable position six will
do that too
go and I'll take that
all right
or something
[Music]
God damn Queen We wiggled but it's like
one of those Wiggles where
the maximum achievement is still a loss
you held on for like yeah for a long
time girl
good thing we made this first to ten
really improves my winning chance
I'm just getting you're doing the same
thing you're you're stream did
stuff that I told them I was gonna do
one better I haven't done that yet
it's a good thing this was planned all
right that's a good thing this is a
known sacrifice
big move here
it's the interesting that of course I
didn't play that on the previous turn
you always there too yeah I know as soon
as Queen D7 what why
oh [__] the night what am I doing oh my
God I'm not taking any of your pieces
My Stream is rubbing off on me
yeah that's the problem it needs to be
over
it was a
try
the lowest of below
he was there
it makes me sick
no we had to get it once I I
um I realized it right as you were going
King F6 and then I was like I couldn't
stop myself I couldn't hold myself back
just the the Primal instinct to free
move Supreme move I didn't realize that
20 20 freaking second yeah we were both
moving fast so you actually tricked
yourself into thinking it was a close
game right
it was not close at all well I had to do
the same thing I streamed it full sense
of hope
oh we love that we love a false sense
false sense of hopes
how do you like your position Mr
Hamilton
uh manageable
you picked a good time to ask yeah
that's a nice move actually I found
there
at least we're breathing here
seem worse
happening
it's not good
let's go
that's remarkably annoying annoying
isn't it
please
be my guest sir
oh [__]
they can move
nobody can move yeah
no no no no no no no no no no no
I don't know no more free moves yeah and
remember it's really close on time yeah
everyone pre-move now
oh oh oh
as long as unfortunately it's like
unfortunately it's like what did I
achieve you know right it's like great
F3 I hate when that happens you get like
a pre-move on your opponent it leads
nowhere you Bishop H6 them and then they
Castle yes and it's all you've done is
prove that you're a dirty pre-moveer
right now
this is known as the worst London this
is a thought opening
unexpected we're gonna roll with the
punches here to fire up the Tilt machine
on a scale of 1 to 11 Dania is a 15 is
from anger right now
um
no no thanks
whoa it must be tried
okay I can get behind this
I think I'm gonna get in front of this
here
no what did I do
freaking taking that
the problem is it's gonna be hard for
you to mate me
or is it
uh how are you gonna get to my king my
friend
I don't know [__] I think I see how
um crap what do I do here
[Music]
foreign
I've lost so many games like that where
they start cutting off your king
especially if you're playing some lag
comper like there's certain people you
just know you have no chance against a
hundred percent I forgot those accounts
like earmarked in my brain oh I I Saw
You release something on this I did I
did of course I'm gonna forget
everything immediately and please do
Rook B5
right out of my video
[Music]
trillion bullet there's uh
pretty Chinese girl yeah exactly a
chance Fighting Chance
elves
small problem
that's a real blunder username
that's a real blender all right
oh my [__] God now are you gonna win
though
[Music]
it's the the one Pawn
one thing I could have wandered
[Music]
oh I guess God girl wow you just got it
fancy you had you had me I got fancy
against the wall
officially refuted all preparations yeah
the video is out the window
we are results oriented
Rook B1 is kind of like a I never want
to have to deal with you right it's just
you you're an annoying piece of garbage
type of move
I mean how cannibalistic of you
[Music]
um
it's the last thing I do
Bishop C2 Queen B1 that's very well
known batteries way too high level for
me
when I get tilted I sometimes say like
this past my like intellectual pay grade
yeah like when I'm in suspecting a
cheater I'm I always like throw these
okay not a problem
surprisingly my position is it actually
got better after that it did it was all
planned
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
how do you like that
I don't I asked you a question I answer
my questions
we have battled
in this type of position so awkward
you're so resilient and these positions
meticulous
what I mean
yes
almost there
one last thing except maybe I'd go king
after we work up five minutes one one
last
man
was it first to ten or best of ten uh
first two times oh it's first inside
okay
obviously you trained your body for a
best of 10.
we're repeating this opening I'm on are
we not
I think it's only right
I gotta get my revenge against this
this thing against me they sting
yeah but you know I'm a resilient guy
and draw you know
whoops
this is like you know when you're
watching a game and the theory
comes in and all of a sudden the
Queens are treated by move 10 and you're
like wait what right
God
oh man
well the guy uh eyes are not what they
used to buy my brain isn't what it used
to be
[Music]
now the scary thing is I don't think I'm
much worse
not now
you're fine
with this again
yeah this is big I'm known for my
resilience here minor piece comebacks
boy do they coordinate well these two
yeah that Bishop on B6 it really made
his presence felt I actually thought for
a second that Queen G3 was intentional
like almost like a statement move you're
right
like this is how good this is how bad
the opening is I can do this now we're
engaged in a real theoretical battle
here sure
recipes
everybody likes this position
huh
this will
okay we're all excited about this great
position great position
when my queen today
fine
we'll acquiesce to the win of a pawn
fancy schmancy
the last time I got fancy we know what
happened
rats
slightly inefficient night maneuver
Jeep tradition
typical Diana
[__] wait I can do this though
we go out of it
yes
wiggle out well I stopped wandering
Pawns in my lifetime
well I blunder Rooks and mates you
blender pawns I think we all have our
you know we have our things to deal with
all right let's go C4 this time of
course it wasn't working uh before yeah
so you've changed it up my [__] video of
course it's just a scam it turns out
[Music]
good thing to prove Rook C1
of course yeah
all right so let's go up here
25 from her
[Music]
ah yes my favorite pieces to have yes
versus a queen game every game has been
like I don't know how this is possible
okay how am I gonna win this though
preferably without blender McQueen down
it's like we can't just have normal
pieces
the night is just so awkward in close
quarters
yeah but now I'm gonna start eating
cute it's gonna earn you some Tinder
dates huh
I got some big moves here
which also didn't work I know it's like
in fact you can prove it with that
movement right exactly
so
would you stop it already just sadness
how many times am I gonna like have to
deal with this goddamn unbelievable rook
and peace versus queen
and I always just get like
it's always like a beautiful game
knows why she's better
[Music]
Bishop F1 that is so high level and then
redeploy the bishop
laughs
oh you are going to Castle into a town
and you're gonna take a video it's got
nothing left
you're looking at a broken man you have
nothing to lose
it
really
well no not really
2003 he's playing wolf versus wolf
is that important
no I'm famous
[Music]
2600.
and this group uh there was something
advocacy one oh yeah
winning 50 times over all right
pin
yeah
well I established a position where it
was all protected
thankfully I got that bra in there this
is where The Comebacks start I think it
reminds me of my Subs
below the belt right there
well all right I'm gonna play something
riveting I'm playing it too
yeah
stop you
no no
God
this is exciting yeah
time for careful don't have too much fun
there all right no I didn't tone it down
is this too much
for the future many I need to be even
now I'm playing here
[Music]
there must be a way out of this
mm-hmm
[Music]
oh you can save away
right
Bishop on F6 is a hero
H5
clinical it looks like you're gonna live
to fight another day unless
pretty much
great
I'm getting the same feeling as my Subs
did probably when they won a game like
Brave
you have some hope
I like your attitude here
and get the hell out
28 ideas
you're just undoing it entirely no yeah
forget it
stupid idea I swear that always happens
whenever I try an idea like that it just
looks so dumb and I'm like what and then
you see like a little macaroni and play
it and it's like amazing
craziest thing you've ever seen
it's my turn for the initiative sir
all right you can't have that
nice
[Music]
hi
stop it
flag yeah
[Music]
jeez
oh my gosh that was very high level end
game
play
it's like where were the governors when
that was happening right whatever
I have scored
although to be fair I really did almost
get the exact like when you think about
it we played 15 sub-battle games and I
actually played 14 games here and even
if I would win one more I'd still score
less than my Subs
yeah your subs really carried the show
today yeah I think they did
in 15 games against Dania and 15 games
against Daniel Subs my Subs out before
me so I think it just goes do you want
to perform them on the board
so you know oh we deserve each other we
deserve each other it's a match made in
heaven thank you Aquila for the subs
cribe
for uh getting that together
absolutely no this is fun I mean it's
it's always hard to set this these kinds
of things up and I I get irrationally
stressed out about like choosing players
because I feel bad about like not
choosing other people but it went super
smoothly today
yeah yeah yeah and now you know the flip
side is when like pick them they do well
they never feel bad when you pick them
they do poorly then you have to deal
with the person in the chat being like I
was stupid
my name first and you didn't honest me
last time and you didn't choose me again
and the worst is of course when they
like have a already seen the person in
their reading category blues and then
they're like oh yeah well what do you
what are you talking about this guy have
a blundered queen in four moves like I
would have done better
exactly
wow
you just gotta find the right time to
like go from the D to the Daniel
it's like it's a certain moment
well the chest process have secured
out of three possible
victories zero so I think we kind of got
gapped today by Dania and his Subs I
will take the I'll do the coaches
interview after the fact and just say
congrats to Daniel's subs for a match
well played
sir that's very classy from the team
cabin you know really down the stretch
in fourth quarter yeah on defensive end
you know our teammates you know didn't
step up to the plate and you know
prepare for Cincinnati next Sunday and
you know just do better but really thank
you this was super super fun congrats to
my amazing
community and team
you guys uh have some learning to do
yeah yeah this is uh this is a lesson
right here today and I think the
the most cliche like interview thing
that I could possibly say and what they
always say in the interviews is good
group of guys you know yeah yeah yeah
you know it's like a great group of guys
you know everyone in the lockers good
locker room energy good group of guys
we'll bounce back it's got a lot of team
leaders and you know I got great team
spirit and resilience and you know just
defensive effort and uh just get ready
for next Sunday
exactly exactly well officially we are
now one to one in sub battles so who
knows when this Trilogy will be
completed probably in two and a half
years but exactly
we'll definitely do a third one to break
the tie-in thanks thanks Simon thanks to
everybody in your chat this is really
super super fun yeah yeah thanks Daniel
it was fun doing the co-commentary I
don't I actually don't do that with
uh-huh pretty much anyone except really
yeah I I don't think for the most part
that it like enhances these things and I
think that most people find that it
enhances it when uh when we do it
together so
privilege I agree that is very very
sweet likewise
cheers buddy thanks for the games thanks
for the beatings
[Music]